sur ce plateau richard labévière
rédacteur en chef de proche et
moyen-orient point ch bonsoir vous est
également l'auteur de reconquérir par la
mer la france face à la nouvelle
géopolitique des océans aux éditions
temporis livre dans lequel vous parler
de la syrie et de la méditerranée vous
êtes spécialiste du moyen-orient
il ya une réunion ce soir au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies à la demande
de la france de la grande-bretagne et
des etats-unis qu'est ce qu'il faut en
attendre vous qui avait été
correspondant permanent pour la tsr aux
nations-unies vous connaissez les
rouages des nations unies non c'est un
rituel récurrent dès que l'armée
gouvernementale syrienne est en passe de
reconquérir une partie de son territoire
national donc les occidentaux présentent
un projet de résolution qui sera à
bloquer soit par voie de veto par la
russie et la chine à tout le moins voir
d'autres membres non permanents
donc cette réunion du conseil de
sécurité sur la situation du leem
il ne changera pas le cours des choses
puisque l'armée gouvernementale syrienne
est en train de reconquérir le dernier
territoire aux mains des jeddi c'est
dans cette affaire assez paradoxal de
voir les pays occidentaux qui défendent
des djihadistes des terroristes qui sont
encerclées les derniers groupes
terroristes encerclés dans la poche du
leem
c'est assez paradoxal de voir les pays
occidentaux défendre des activistes
djaballah ne sera de déchets d'autres
groupes soutenus par à miss à venir
défendue par les pays occidentaux mais
ça c'est ccsa c'est depuis le début du
conflit depuis mars 2011 on voit les
pays occidentaux aux côtés des groupes
jihadistes qui veulent absolument
renverser le
le gouvernement syrien et renverser
bachar al assad donc on reste dans la
même partition s'il vous plaît justement
le gouvernement syrien de bachar al
assad at il des possibilités de
reprendre totalement le contrôle de son
territoire qui allait pouvoir de
nuisance des groupes terroristes sur
place s'ils voulaient le les autorités
syriennes ont pu reconquérir dirait 85 à
90% du territoire de la série historique
depuis le tournant de cette guerre
civile ou globale c'est-à-dire depuis
décembre 2016
lorsque l'armée syrienne a pu
reconquérir la partie est d'alep qui là
aussi était tenu par des activistes de
job at elle n'ose pas et surtout des
activistes ouïgours chinois qui avaient
été amenés à alep par les services turc
donc là avec l'aide de des forces
aériennes russes avec l'aide du
hezbollah libanais et des gardiens
iraniens de la révolution l'armée
syrienne est en passe de reconquérir
l'ensemble de son territoire et de libé
la dernière poche qui échappent à cette
reconquête encore quelques problèmes si
vous voulez à l'aise de l'euphrate dans
ce qu'on appelle improprement leur java
dans la partie kurde mais où là
visiblement un accord justement entre la
turquie et la russie a pu établir une
zone tampon et a pu justement déboucher
sur une solution
c'est ce que recherchent actuellement
les diplomaties la diplomatie russe avec
la turquie
justement à vous parler de la turquie de
la russie on a entendu dmitri peskov le
porte parole du kremlin dire que
vladimir poutine suit de près la
situation ils envisageraient de voir son
homologue turc recep tayyip erdogan
prochainement c'est qu'il ya des
militaires du fsb qui aurait et
tués selon moscou qu'est-ce qu'il faut
attendre de cette rencontre entre
poutine et ardoines cette rencontre il
est essentiel puisque justement c'est
une entente entre les diplomatie
d'ankara et de moscou qui en décembre
2016 avait permis de trouver une
solution sur aleph est ainsi de 2,2
d'opérer un grand basculement dans cette
guerre civile en syrie et moscou sergueï
lavrov le chef de la diplomatie russe
sait très bien que rien ne peut se faire
aujourd'hui à nîmes et alès de
l'euphrate sont une entente une entente
avec la turquie en reproduit sans ce
qu'on appelle le format d'astana c'est à
dire en incluant au négociations
non seulement la turquie qui est un rôle
essentiel dans cette affaire mais aussi
l'iran voire à la marge d'autres
d'autres groupes d'appui notamment le
hezbollah libanais justement vous parlez
de l'iran et du hezbollah israël qui
vise justement
dès à présent cinq soldats iraniens et
du hezbollah en syrie damas dit avoir
intercepté des missiles israéliens la
nuit dernière
est ce que justement avec fait il n'ya
pas des risques de dommages collatéraux
alors là les informations dont vous
faites état sourds effectivement
confirmée de plusieurs sources
militaires et il est clair que l'armée
syrienne a fait des progrès dans sa
défense antiaérienne notamment grâce à
la division de matériel et de batteries
anti aériennes russes
maintenant si vous voulez le les
éléments de langage de l'armée
israélienne disant qu'elle cible des
éléments du hezbollah ou iranien en
syrie relève plutôt d'une guerre de
communiqués puisqu'au jour au jour
d'aujourd'hui les combattants du
hezbollah libanais et des pasdarans ne
sont pas engagés de manière compacte et
ne tiennent pas des positions sur leur
propre manière à leur propre drapeau ses
combattants sont intégrés dans des
unités de l'armée syrienne
conventionnelle donc n'ayant pas
nous sachions de deux d'agents de
renseignements sur le terrain les les
analystes militaires considèrent que ces
annonces du gouvernement de tel-aviv
relève plutôt d'une d'une guerre
psychologique d'une guerre de
communication de communiquer pour
voulant montrer ainsi que israël ou
allemands de tel-aviv maintient une
pression maximum sur la syrie et par
parent par extension sur sur liront sur
sur l'aide que l'iran apporte au
gouvernement de bachar al assad
dernière question richard labévière il
nous reste à peine une minute ankara a
menacé damas de riposte est ce qu'il ya
une risque d' escalade des tensions dans
disons que là aussi on est dans du on
est dans l'unique narratif le garant de
d'une escalade et seriez il avoit fait
la diplomatie russe qui depuis
l'engagement militaire russe massif en
syrie depuis septembre 2015
justement et c'est d'amener
progressivement les autorités turques et
damas à se parler et sur la zone kurde à
l'est de l'euphrate et sur la poche
d'idlib
les turcs sont très embêtés avec l'ip
parce que ils ne peuvent pas se
déconsidérer ils doivent sauver des
activistes qui l'ont soutenu depuis des
années il faut se souvenir que les
services turcs ont favorisé l'émergence
de des chais ont soutenu des activistes
d'al qaïda de joe battat ne sera donc
seul aujourd'hui la diplomatie russe
peut faire entendre raison à un grave
merci richard labévière d'avoir répondu
à nos questions